over the years you've been a test you've
done a lot of amazing breakthrough ideas
and Engineering all of it from the data
engine to The Human Side all of it can
you speak to why you chose to leave
Tesla
basically as I described that Ren I
think over time during those five years
I've kind of uh gotten myself into a
little bit of a managerial position most
of my days were you know meetings and
growing the organization and making
decisions about a sort of high level
strategic decisions about the team and
what it should be working on and so on
and uh
it's kind of like a corporate executive
role and I can do it I think I'm okay at
it but it's not like fundamentally what
I what I enjoy and so I think uh when I
joined uh there was no computer vision
team because Tesla was just going from
the transition of using mobileye a
third-party vendor for all of its
computer vision to having to build its
computer vision system so when I showed
up there were two people training deep
neural networks and they were training
them at a computer at their at their
legs like uh downstairs kind of basic
classification task yeah and so
I kind of like grew that into what I
think is a fairly respectable deep
learning team a massive compute cluster
a very good um data annotation
organization and uh I was very happy
with where that was it became quite
autonomous and so I kind of stepped away
and I uh you know I'm very excited to do
much more technical things again
yeah and kind of like we focus on AGI
what was this soul searching like
because you took a little time off and
think like what um how many mushrooms
did you take no I'm just uh I mean what
what was going through your mind the
human lifetime is finite yeah he did a
few incredible things you're you're one
of the best teachers of AI in the world
you're one of the best and I don't mean
that I mean that in the best possible
way you're one of the best tinkerers in
the AI world meaning like understanding
the fundamental fundamentals of how
something works by building it from
scratch and playing with it with the
basic intuitions it's like Einstein fine
when we're all really good at this kind
of stuff like a small example of a thing
to to play with it to try to understand
it uh so that and obviously now with us
that you help build a team of machine
learning
um uh like engineers and a system that
actually accomplishes something in the
real world so given all that like what
was the soul searching like
well it was hard because obviously I
love the company a lot and I love I love
Elon I love Tesla I want um
it was hard to leave I love the team
basically
um
but
yeah I think actually I would
potentially like interested in
revisiting it maybe coming back at some
point uh working in Optimus working in
AGI at Tesla uh I think Tesla is going
to do incredible things it's basically
like
uh it's a massive large-scale robotics
kind of company with a ton of In-House
talent for doing really incredible
things and I think uh
human robots are going to be amazing I
think autonomous transportation is going
to be amazing all this is happening at
Tesla so I think it's just a really
amazing organization so being part of it
and helping it along I think was very
basically I enjoyed that a lot yeah it
was basically difficult for those
reasons because I love the company uh
but you know I'm happy to potentially at
some point come back for act two but I
felt like at this stage
I built the team it felt autonomous and
uh I became a manager and I wanted to do
a lot more technical stuff I wanted to
learn stuff I wanted to teach stuff and
uh I just kind of felt like it was a
good time for for a change of pace a
little
bit